Big Bang Theory is going out with a bang
and kaley cuoco and the cast have some
strong feelings about it I was like
crying when I heard about it
ariana grande proof she is Nicki Minaj's
write or die and Scott Eastwood is
getting all kinds of candidate about a
sex life I can't believe it but after 12
seasons the Big Bang Theory is making
its final orbit CBS announced the show's
12th season will be its last four TVs
number one comedy are we ready for that
which means Kaley Cuoco won't be
collecting that reported 1 million
dollar check an episode now that's the
real tragedy to be honest our girl is
filling the fields in fact Kaley posted
that she's drowning in tears quote this
ride has been a dream come true and as
life-changing as it gets no matter when
it was going to end my heart would have
always been broken into
Kaley has told us that if the cards were
on the table she'd be down to go past
season 12 I've always said that if we if
we're lucky enough to work something out
where we go past that I would be
thrilled I'm definitely on board for it
I don't know what the plan is or how
that's gonna go but I I love being part
of the show and I think it'd be really
stupid to just say no or to you know
find some there's just nothing better
and I feel super grateful that was
possible but you know what Kaley is not
the only cast member sad about BBT
ending
Mayim Bialik posted this photo with
Cassidy's Kunal Nayyar and Melissa raw
before the big news broke she wrote on
her website quote am i happy of course
not
it's very sad I fear it's going to be
very hard to not cry and all T no shade
but reports say was Jim Parsons who was
ready to leave the speculation is his
movie and theater career might have been
a factor but his rep is not commenting
still Jim posted quote I feel such
gratitude for our devoted viewers I will
miss all of you and all of this more
than I can say it but don't worry big
bang fans we still got 24 new episodes
to go and they haven't even started yet
and don't get me started on ariana
grande again because she's Nicki Minaj
our BFF goals and I can get enough
already decided to sweeten the ongoing
shade between Nikki and Travis Scott the
singer performed a sweetener
listening session for fans in Chicago
Scooter Braun popped up on stage to
praise Arianna and declare that the
album would 100% make it to number one
and that's when Ari took this little dig
at Travis Scott who currently has the
number-one album 100 per se hey you
gotta speak your truth and you got a rep
your friends and you know Nikki who
dropped Queen last week has been
dragging Travis and how he came to have
the top-selling album Jarvis Scott you
better Travis Scott you played yourself
also for having your friend come on the
internet talking up for you you're
stupid you're a big man you got your
homeboy talking for you and you got your
girlfriend posting tor passes saying you
sold albums stop it I'm uncomfortable
and scared today on Queen radio she
addressed that TMZ video going around
with Kylie avoiding her at the VMAs
saying on the record quote - love Kylie
and that's not gonna change it's obvious
she's got a ride for her man she's a
dope girl and has done nothing wrong
okay whew I don't know where that was
gonna go so but can I be honest oh this
is the last we talked about this
billboard can you release this week's
chart so we can get over it a short
world queen they're both fired let's
move on and that's what I'm gonna do
not gonna lie guys it was a hashtag slow
news day today and I was thirsty for
some stories and sure enough Scott
Eastwood has clinched it yeah that's
right Clinton son is dishing on his past
and present loves and his advanced sex
life he had Emily Moore's doctor of
human sexuality as a guest on his live
live better podcast I'm single single
dating okay yeah are you having sex good
I am having sex lots of it with one
person or several people you know it
depends on when you ask me all right
then Scott noted by the way we have more
from that candid podcast up at et
online.com but that's it for today
told you guys a struggle City over here
so go enjoy the rest of your day
wherever you are and come back tomorrow
from you